افاد مراسل الجزيره باطلاق صواريخ من جنوب
لبنان باتجاه مواقع جل العلام الاسرائيلي
في الجليل الاعلى صباح اليوم في هذه
الاثناء اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي انه رصد
اطلاق اربع قذائف صاروخيه بعد انطلاق
صافرات الانذار للمره الثانيه تحديدا في
بلده شلومي في الجليل الغربي وكان حزب
الله نفذ خلال الساعات ال 2 الماضيه تسع
عمليات ضد مواقع للقوات
الاسرائيليه من الناقوره في جنوب لبنان
ينضم الينا مراسلنا جوني طانيوس ومن
الجليل الاعلى تنضم مراسلتنا جيفارا
البديري اهلا بكم جيفارا وجوني دعني ابنا
معك جوني ضعنا في صوره ما يجري من الجانب
اللبناني
تفضل في الواقع ليلى هو تصعيد مستمر في
هذه المناطق الحدوديه واخر تجلياته اطلاق
الصواريخ من هنا من القطاع الغربي باتجاه
مواقع عسكريه اسرائيليه وتحديدا موقع جل
العلام وقد سمع دوي هذه الصواريخ هنا في
هذه المناطق الحدوديه طبعا عمليه اطلاق
الصواريخ تاتي بعد ليل متوتر هنا ايضا في
المناطق الحدوديه تحديدا من خلال الغارات
التي شنتها المقاتلات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
على منزل في بلده بيت ليف ما ادى الى مقتل
اربعه اشخاص وقد نعى حزب الله اربعه من
عناصره بسبب هذه الغاره بالاضافه الى غاره
اخرى شنت على بلده دير عامس وهي بلده غير
حدوديه بلده خلفيه نوعا ما ولكن من دون
وقوع اي اصابات بعد هذه الغارات
الاسرائيليه نفذ حزب الله مجموعه من
العمليات العسكريه خلال ساعات الليل
باتجاه المواقع العسكريه الاسرائيليه
ويمكن القول ان حزب الله كثف الليله
الماضيه من هذه العمليات باتجاه المواقع
العسكر يه الاسرائيليه وتجمعات الجنود
الاسرائيليين واستخدم في بعض هذه العمليات
صواريخ من نوع بركان وفي المجمل حزب الله
يوم امس نفذ تسع عمليات عسكريه خلال ساعات
هذا اليوم كانت الابرز من بينها العمليه
التي نفذها باتجاه سكنه عسكريه في منطقه
الجولان السوري المحتل خلف مزارع شبعه
المحتله وقال حزب الله انه استخدم في هذه
العمليه صاروخ من نوع فلق واحد وهو صاروخ
ايراني الصنع يبلغ مداه نحو 10 كيلومترات
وهي المره الاولى التي يعلن فيها حزب الله
انه استخدم هذا النوع من الصواريخ والمره
الاولى التي تطال هذه الصواريخ هذا المدى
وهذه الثكنه العسكريه وبعدها بنحو ساعتين
تقريبا اعلن حزب الله ايضا انه اعاد
استهداف هذه الثكنه العسكريه ولكن بصواريخ
من نوع كاتيوشا ويمكن القول بالتالي ان
حزب الله كثف واضاف الى التصعيد والى
نعم من خ هذه اليه ومن خلال هذا النوع من
الصواريخ الذي استخدمه بالاضافه طبعا الى
القصف المدفعي الاسرائيلي المستمر طوال
ساعات اليوم على عدد كبير من المناطق
الحدود